some people find me extremely annoying
in science because i'm basically um
i quite rude and disruptive not in a
rude you know so to people say they're
ugly or stupid or anything like that i
just say
you
you know you're wrong or why do you
think this and and something i
gift i got given by society when i was
very young because i was in a
in the learning difficulties class at
school is i was told i was stupid
and so i know i know i'm stupid
but i always wanted to be smart right i
always i remember going to school going
maybe today they're going to tell me i
i'm not as stupid as i was yesterday and
it was always disappointed always and so
when i went into academia and everyone
says you're wrong i was like
join the queue yeah
because it allowed me to walk through
the you know the wall so i think that
people like to always imagine science is
a bit like living in a japanese house
the paper walls and everyone sits in
their paper in their room
and i annoy people because i walk
straight through the wall not be because
why should why should i be a chemist and
not a mathematician why should i be a
mathematician not computer scientist
because if the problem requires us to to
walk through those walls
um but
i'm i like walking through the walls
like but i as long then i have to put up
you know i have to do good side i have
to win the people in those rooms
across by good science by
taking their criticisms and addressing
them head-on
and i think we must do that and and i
think that i i try and do that in my own
way and i i i kind of love walking
through the walls
and it it it gives me it's difficult for
me personally it's quite painful
but it always leads to a deeper
understanding of the people i'm with in
particular you know the arguments i have
with all sorts of interesting minds
because
i want to solve the problem or i want to
understand more about why i exist um you
know that's
that's that's it really and i think we
have to not dismiss science on that
basis i think we can we can work with
science
you